get ready for the battle of the Joes
moderate Democrat Joe manchin sounds
like he's open to ditching his own party
potentially challenging Joe Biden in
2024.
if you run for office in 2024.
you're going to run as a Democrat
Chuck I haven't made a decision what I'm
going to do in 2024. so everything on
the table there's basically only one
other thing the presidency is that
something you would do outside the
Democratic party the only thing I can
tell you is what I will do is whatever I
can when I make my decision what I think
is the best that I can support and
represent the people of West Virginia
but also be true to this country and the
constitution of this country do you want
President Biden North seek reelection
well you have to make that decision if
he does you're not ready to support him
I haven't decided on anything I'm going
to do until I see what what the lay of
the land is going to be at that time
because this country needs to unite
interesting and Mansion says this is a
big reason why
I think he's been pulled to the left too
far and I think I've told him that yeah
I've been upfront with that that Center
Center is what the country wants that's
what the people want in America
Republican ideas aren't always bad and
the Democrats don't has all don't have
all the answers and vice versa
Jessica this is very interesting I'm
very excited by this because all the
while I was thinking that the Republican
Party would be cleaving right if Trump
decides to run on his own and that would
be absolute disaster but what happens if
the Democrats do the same thing then you
have four candidates and you might end
up getting the best candidate you ever
got because of the of the double
cleaving the best one will be the one
that holds everybody together the double
Cliff yes what do you say to that
Jessica double cleave yeah um
interesting
unfortunately we're just too much of a
two-party system for an independent to
really I mean Angus King obviously
doesn't Bernie does it but they're
Democrats right they caucus full-time
with the Democrats they rarely even push
back against them this would be
something very different and probably
what Kristen Cinema is going to be doing
in Arizona now and she just got her
first formal um challenge uh Congressman
Reuben Gallego got in this morning to
that race
it doesn't bode well for Democrats
success or even left-leaning independent
so I think that that you know Carrie
Lake said she's exploring the idea of a
senate run I worry that hands Arizona to
a republican but in West Virginia Joe
manchin what he didn't mention in the
interview is now they don't like him
there anymore so he won by 42 points in
2018 and now he's one of the top 10 most
unpopular senators in the country his
approvals at 38 and after he went in
with Joe Biden on the inflation
reduction act the West Virginians said
hey I thought we had this independent
minded It's fine that you were a
Democrat but now not so much so I I
think it's more about that than anything
else but certainly if he switched to
another party Democrats would have
absolutely no shot on the state level
um to keep that seat Jessica brings up
an interesting point the independent
mind of Joe manchin I find this
incredibly startling you know why Dana
because I have a sports analogy I'd like
to share with you okay the most
important person on the football team is
a quarterback because everybody else's
vote is canceled out right a lineman has
another alignment receiver the
quarterback is the one that scrambles
that's when you can make the decisions
isn't that kind of what what say Mansion
might be for the Democrats Rand Paul for
the Republicans they end up in every
every issue the most important person
because you know what everybody else is
going to do so they get to flirt they
get to attract people they become very
appealing you see my point I do I think
I watch the quarterback do again I don't
really know what I was talking about I'm
just kidding oh God so I feel like we
have this conversation about Mansion
over and over again yes and one I don't
think he's going to become a republican
because if he was going to do that he
would have done it by now and if he does
it now it would just look totally Craven
and not based on any principle it would
be based on trying to get reelected in
West Virginia he is popular in West
Virginia he did win by a large margin
has that is it is it too far gone now
for him there maybe I have a feeling I
part of me thinks that Chuck Todd asked
the question about 2024 because Mansion
wanted the question and that the staff
had let Chuck Todd know that that might
be a good question to ask him you know
if I were you I would certainly ask that
question because he maybe is flirting
with the idea and he might have people
who are saying you should really give it
a shot I just feel that Biden would love
a primary Challenge from the left so
that then he could tell all the see how
reasonable I am and how moderate I am
I'm normal Joe you don't want these kind
of nuts but imagine
I'm not worried so much that uh he's
going to take away votes from a
conservative a republican I I just don't
think he's going to
have a shot at the presidency I have to
say now I'm fully prepared to eat my
words and this pen not much calories in
that judge you are an expert on Mansions
what say you
the only thing that you know and there's
not that much I can say about Mansion I
was impressed with him you know and when
a guy when he talks about the division
in this country I think that he speaks
about it with a great deal of Gravitas
because he in cinema took a lot of crap
from the left and from the Democrats
I've never seen anything like it I mean
they were followed into bathrooms they
were criticized I mean they understand
the importance of coming together so in
that regard I kind of I see him as a guy
who maybe does have the intention of
bringing the country together the
inflation reduction Act is when he
disappointed me you know then he just
went pure politics I don't know I know
that he may have won big in 2018 uh
Jessica but I know in 2020 uh Donald
Trump won big in 2020 by 40 points so uh
in that same area so it'll be
interesting to see I really think
there's a future for Mansion I I don't
give up on him back that quickly yeah
Jesse what are your sources on the beach
telling you any interesting tidbits is
Mansion running well my sources inside
of his houseboat oh yeah I've been
telling me he's seriously considering a
run really yeah wow I've met him a few
times he's a good guy I like him
personally he's a regular dude and then
he just breaks my heart he votes for
Kavanaugh and then he votes for the
inflation reduction act and I'm tired of
my heart being broken hasn't it been
broken enough and I hate when the
Senator's staff any Senator stuff tells
me what they think I should ask the
senator does that happen to you all the
time and I never asked them I hit him
with curveballs that's how I keep them
on their toes
the only way he survives if he switches
parties and becomes a Republican and
I've been begging him to do that this
show has been begging him to do that for
many years not me and he still won't do
it I love the political lexicon that we
just rattled off
double cleavage uh Angus King leaving
Cleveland now
his heart has been broken
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now